[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
adam sandler's got another great movie
ranked number one it's hustle available
now on netflix and uh it's about a down
on his luck basketball scout discovers
an extraordinary player abroad brings
him back to the united states and does
so without his team's approval and then
the story begins from there sandman
joining us on the program you know when
i first saw the movie and i said this to
you i didn't realize
anthony edwards was going to be that
good of an actor so the minnesota
timberwolves okay how do you find out
that anthony edwards can act
i mean you just assumed it was uh and
good to see you danny you look handsome
uh i uh
my man uh juancho those guys were
teammates juancho called jeremiah who
directed the movie and said i think my
my teammate might want to play uh kermit
the bad guy in the movie and then we all
talked about it i said anthony edwards
man that guy's
he's incredible and i knew he was
already funny from just seeing him being
interviewed and and just everything he
says kind of makes you laugh and
and uh that was it they just those two
just felt so relaxed together danny so
so you you'd say try this try that
it was stuff written there was stuff
that you said what would you say in this
situation and then they just they just
felt loose together
but do you try not to get them to act
like how do you how do you talk to them
so
because sometimes when you say hey act
then you act like you're acting as
opposed to trying to be natural
[Music]
it's ridiculous every one of the guys
who's in the league
that's in the movie you didn't have to
tell them much like they would not
freeze up they wouldn't make it it
wasn't stiff they were just naturally
loose everybody would say
whatever was written they would say fine
then you say go ahead say what you would
say and they'd kind of look at each
other i'd say i think i'd say this go
ahead say that they they just say it
feel loose try and and uh
just calm
kyle lowry
matisse all those guys
in the gym when they when they would
just say this stuff you're just like
this is cool man and you don't have to
do take two they were just relaxed
did you find this or did somebody find
it to give it to you
not exactly sure it was like lebron's
company and maverick they had it and joe
roth
the they uh joe roth
he did the water boy with me and and all
these
this stuff he was the head of disney
when i and when i did uh the water boy
and i then i did anger management with
joe and i did a bunch of movies with joe
and his son zach
uh it works with joe now and those guys
all brought me the movie
and then i read it and i was like wow
this could be cool as hell man because
it's it's very real feel
and i'm that i'm at the age now where
i'm
old enough to be this guy and and i
ain't gonna play um uh in my head i was
like and if when we were first
doing the movie then i would i would
talk like i was bo sometimes the young
guy be like and then when i take that
shot because i'm so used to being the uh
the guy in the movie that's like the uh
the fake athlete but i would be like oh
no no i mean when when uh juancho takes
that shot
what's the reaction been
i got my favorite text last night from
iverson
alan iverson texted me that
that was that was quite a moment man and
he said he watched it with his kids and
he dug it and uh just said a lot of nice
things and i told him how much i love
them and we we we he's you talk to alan
ever we had him on a couple of uh weeks
ago he
he was great
isn't he just a gentle cool bastard man
i love him yeah he was great okay
lebron's role in this when the movie
gets started is what
well i think that
first of all they brought me to movie
they allowed me to kind of do my my
thing and and uh start
filling out you know the director and
the uh
and the feel of the whole thing and then
um the rewrites and we all kind of had a
this guy will fetters came on and did
rewrites and then jeremiah and
um
zagar became the director i mean
jeremiah first and then will and then
all this stuff came together
uh
and then uh
lebron and and uh
uh
maverick and this kid spencer who works
with those guys they just made sure
i mean they would read drafts make sure
it feels authentic and then also um
the nba was was
definitely much
it was at our fingertips because those
guys were involved they they would get
footage other players p just just the
lebron name is going to make it feel
like all right
this is going to be a legit movie
when you're comedian but this this isn't
a funny movie
right but there's funny in it but how
how tempting is it to add more humor
being a comedian
i guess i just was trying to do it like
and by the way you i you were
in in on it in the ground floor i called
you up i told you we're doing this thing
i want your help and you read it and you
you gave me some great notes on the
script and telling me what's good and
and what didn't feel like uh the real
deal on it but i didn't get credited as
a producer or
co-writer i mean i checked i checked the
whole imdb i'm not even listed as an
actor
in the movie
well the the uh netflix thought it would
take away from the authenticity they
said they said
they said dan is you know like
at this moment in time dan dan will
actually
just you know make people think of other
thoughts such as
uh
new jogging
uh uh you know
anger anger angry uh ping pong
you're struggling you're struggling here
to say you know what i really screwed up
dan
no no no i never screwed up by the way
saw the movie in philadelphia you came
on screen sitting next to my mother what
does she whisper i loved him
she's only human i mean
i don't know what you've done with mom
but it's fine yeah she's a lady that's
my demo my demo is
his mother's absolutely
the movie is hustle it's available on
netflix right now now you also shot a
movie
did you shoot the movie with jennifer
aniston
after this
yes i shot that in hawaii and paris and
you were welcome on both no i was not no
i was not no you said no to hawaii i
told you i said eddie vetter's waiting
to hang and you're like hey man i'm just
doing my thing and eddie kept going is
he coming is he coming and and danny p
is like i'll get there when i get there
and then i said okay you blew us off on
hawaii you want to come to paris you go
i speak english man i'm not that is not
i did not say that you're you were a sad
man in paris you're the only guy i know
goes to paris and you're sad because you
have nothing to do you're texting me
i know i miss i miss my uh family
okay when did you
go
nude swimming
oh with joe vesey
uh no no i never went nude swimming i
never that was all part of a uh made-up
bit but in my life i think
i went nude water skiing in new
hampshire one time all all my friends
were doing it wait wait you think you
did it feels like you would remember
i was 14 or something
and uh all everybody was getting laughs
off the the nude uh
water skiing and i think
okay but you did i did see the picture
of you with your your shirt off in oh
well that was a tough moment for me
didn't you realize there would be
paparazzi i thought because i'm in
another country
i was in this cool oh they don't have
cameras there i didn't think they would
care everybody was nude running around
there i was like they don't care about
us a shirtless chubby guy and then all
of a sudden god damn it
i don't even know where the guy was or
the lady was who shot me i wonder if
they thought wow that that's a
unattractive woman there who's got her
top off
why is that
that lady have a pizza in the water yeah
wow oh that's oh that's adam sandler
yeah
whatever no i was fine in that picture
by the way if i had my shirt off now
goodness gracious i think i'm about
maybe 40 to 70 more right now
you look good i saw you stand up well
you've been hitting the the gym yeah you
know i'm just uh
taking care of myself for the next role
that's right
when's the next movie that i'm in i
don't know but you want to be in
something uh this summer i got to come i
got i don't really know what i'm doing
next i don't know anything i i'm kind of
like
oh i'm doing this acting brothers
oh
we're doing this
they would they they the movie that'd be
cool buddy they love you would the
safeties let me in the movie
they're not giving you a producer credit
they don't give anyone no no i don't
want a producer credit yeah yes they
would it might make sense i'm talking to
them today okay
yeah you definitely would crush that now
those guys they did uh uncut gems like
they're pretty serious yes sir so are
you you got that sick side
also you want me to be
like a
dark danny danny darko it's not danny
and this in the safties you're gonna
come up with a new name and you you'd be
awesome in this thing i i bet that they
would be excited okay so you're shooting
that this summer
no i'm not shooting that until like
january i'm not doing much i'm i'm
producing this summer doing some some
stuff going to toronto i don't even know
danny i don't know what i'm doing right
now i'm getting getting old man waking
up my groin hurts you got any fixes for
the groin i've been
got a pull groin i've been being doing
pt it's it's gets better than how do you
hurt your groin
i i i think i thought it was basketball
but they said it was too much golf
i ripped my little labrum wait you hurt
yourself playing golf
when we would do it in the pandemic
i i rented a place on a golf course and
i haven't golfed in 20 years and all of
a sudden i was playing 36 holes a day
and they the they said that was a bad
move
but when you were when you did happy
gilmore
had you had you played golf then yes i
got my dad i used to golf with my dad
but i stopped when my kid when sadie was
born i stopped golfing i was a member at
riv didn't golf at all i went there
twice in 15 years or something and uh
uh and then uh uh all of a sudden i got
uh oh yeah no it was when i was in
hawaii during the pandemic i started
golfing again and then and then i got
this stupid groin i can't finish a turn
i like that the last time you played at
riviera didn't i talk to you right after
that where
two older guys yelled at you
[Laughter]
it was insane
i don't i won't get into it because uh
one of the guys i i i met and he's a
nice guy but when they were going at it
they were they were older and they were
angry
one only one of them was angry one of
them was angry the other guy was very
nice
do you play with anybody
no
i just go out and do i mean on occasion
i find myself with somebody they'll tell
me to come hang out but uh most of the
time i just i live on the same street so
i just kind of go let me go down there i
played i played with uh luke wilson the
other day
maybe
yeah luke's uh
is he a good golfer very good very good
and cheatle i play with cheetos
sometimes too and they they they
uh but normally i just kind of shoot
down there i don't even play that mu i
play four holes go back home i see
everyone's gotta get dressed i go how
long are you gonna be they always say
like we'll be ready in a half hour i go
all right that's two hours so i go and
play seven holes or something
uh your favorite scene in the movie is
what
rubbing the queen's feet queen latifah
we could have done that for days
okay
that that that um you might have to
explain the scene a little bit more
queen latifah plays your way
i give her a foot rub
every time they would say cut i would
say what it's over they say another
angle
the queen's feet and enjoy now she was
nice man she was great and you know i
loved all the hoop and being out there
and getting to know all the guys and uh
man i was with coach wright
he came to philadelphia the screening
the other night i just got to know
so many players so many it was the best
shoot it was the best shoot i lived in a
house with a with a basketball court in
it i mean i was all hoop that's all i
did i think that wasn't the best thing
for my groin but
it's okay
uh the basketball player who took things
uh more seriously on the court
was who
nobody took it too serious but i did see
some
cool stuff one one time i saw trey
and trey young trae young and anthony
edwards just screwing around from half
court
just going matching each other take a
shot one would hit the other guy would
go
and hit
and um
it was just funny to see that it was
like nine in the morning everyone's a
little in a day as you look up and see
those guys effortlessly hitting half
court shots
like like it's a normal shot i know
there's a struggle i know you know they
don't like i did at the jcc as a kid
when we'd all line up at half court
and throw the ball and somebody would
hit the rim we'd be like oh my god these
guys
these little natural shots boom i know
the range is incredible what room is
this in your house
this is not my house this is my office
uh
i don't even know it doesn't look good
but there's a bunch of pictures of my
family behind me if you if i turn this
around you would see uh oh let me show
you this gift somebody just got me this
is full um adam sandler
all right i got you the movie is uh
hustle available now on netflix look at
this thing danny
that's a hoot oh i like that that's
pretty cool huh a golden hustle basket
there it came with one other thing for
you
i know radio does it doesn't play but
there's some booze here for you it's uh
it's a i think it's a good one i don't
know
all right yeah i think that's like 400
or 500 dollars that champagne
well gotta go me me you and schwartzen
yeah but you don't drink
i'll let you do it
what's the best yeah i can do that i i
still tell people when we were in hawaii
and you introduced me to dave matthews
and i went to shake his hand and i
spilled my beer all over him when we
were at the table
he handed it like
he did
i said i'm sorry and uh
he was surprisingly
uh generous and very funny oh funny as
hell gentle dude yeah
yep um well good luck with the movie
with our movie
danny we did good again now i got one
thing i need to ask you i have a beer i
have a beard yeah
who who do you know that trims their own
beard and it comes out good because i
got like every couple weeks i go to a
guy do you have seaton uh seton trims
his beard well yeah but it that's very
generous calling it a beard
and it's not exactly exactly the
strongest
but do you trim it with scissors or a
razor no they have those beard trimmers
i'm afraid because
uh it one mistake and then you it's it's
over for you well why don't you have
your wife do it
she didn't want to touch the beard she
literally touched it last night and went
why do you have that
wow
i don't know i don't know
why do you have the beard it's covering
one of the biggest necks of all time
well keep the beard but have neck
reduction surgery
i can't do that i can't look you in the
eyes and say i did that so i'd rather
discover it would you do cosmetic
surgery
you know i never have i i do i do
fantasize looking better than this
she deserves better but
it's disgusting what's happened but i'm
not kidding i saw some pictures of me in
like 8th and 9th grade and i i get what
she was attracted to it was fantastic
back then yeah but what happened
danny the same thing that's happened to
you buddy
oh okay return fire
got you yep
i'll take off my shirt if you take off
your shirt
no not right now but i'm gonna get in
shape i'm gonna get in shape this summer
i have one i have a friend every time i
talk to him i say how you doing he goes
i need to lose 20 i'm going to do that
too
i don't know man you said that last time
but i but i'm going to get it done how
about you and me we're going to be nude
on the on the uh on the lake
we're going to be water skiing on the
lake
would you ever do that now at this age
you can't right yeah that's illegal it's
illegal
they don't allow that at most lakes now
well it was probably illegal when you
did it
not not that i was aware i think
everyone else was doing it it was fine
all right thanks buddy
i miss you love you too talk to you soon
that's adam sandler the movie is hustle
we've made it number one we
team effort